Russian isander missiles like the ones
seen in this B Russian State media
footage are capable of launching nuclear
warheads they've been popping up at
military training grounds in Belarus as
Russia aims to expand its nuclear
capabilities there is ganders are only
manufactured in Russia they're
distinguishable by the Dual set of
wheels on the main chassis and this
rectangular compartment from which the
missile
launches Russian President Vladimir
Putin has repeatedly boasted about the
transfer of them to bellarus ratcheting
up the threat of a nuclear attack from
there while it's difficult to know if
Russia has transferred actual nuclear
warheads we can see that it's expanding
its capability to launch them outside of
its borders in bellarus right on Ukraine
and NATO's doorstep it's forced Ukraine
to Grapple with questions of a potential
nuclear threat in the north while trying
to push forward a major counter
offensive in the South Russia has been
building up this capability in b since
before the full-scale invasion of
Ukraine in 2022 much of it in the asichi
district which has become a hub for
nuclear capable weapons transferred from
Russia this January 2022 satellite image
from there shows the beginning of this
expansion here over a dozen isander
components are seen parked at a training
center then in February of 2023 State
media footage from the same location
shows Bellar Russian soldiers training
with the Russian supplied isander
there a few miles away from this
training ground in July 2023 we can see
a garage to store some of the Russian
launchers the garage didn't exist in
August
2022 elsewhere in the ASAP poovi
District nuclear arms Watchers began
monitoring another storage facility in
Spring of 2023 after a leaked us
intelligence report revealed Russia was
considering it to house nuclear
warheads nuclear weapons researchers
have spotted clues in satellite imagery
there last summer this area used to be
covered with trees only the Outer
Perimeter had fencing but by Spring of
2023 these additional double layers of
fencing in the inner perimeter were
added while other features would still
need to be added multiple layers of
fencing are a signature of Russian
nuclear warhead storage
sites this one in kenrad Russia has
similar layers of fencing
the training grounds and other
facilities in bellarus where iskanders
have been spotted along with the
expansion of storage arsenals represent
an important strategic expansion of
Russia's capability to launch a nuclear
weapon